hello everyone so I'm near Tran I'm the
director of clinical chemistry and
point-of-care testing at the University
of California Davis Medical Center and
there we are there on the first slide up
in Sacramento California a quick
background we're the northernmost
University of California Medical Center
we serve a wide range of patients across
the Central Valley
we're 618 bed hostel and the number
continues to grow as we're growing as a
Medical Center quick key facts about us
we're one of the larger burn centers in
the country
we also our Cancer Center designated NCI
Cancer Center as well as the number one
kidney transplant center in the country
seems like we'll kind of call back to in
this presentation of course today's talk
is on burn sepsis and acute kidney
injury and unique populations in the
promise of artificial intelligence quick
disclosures we have none the studies I
will present to you today our
investigator initiated studies in fact
some where supported in part by the
National Institutes of Health and also
want to give due credit to dr. hua and
rashidi who's also listed on this her
slide right here who's our artificial
intelligence expert at UC Davis so
definitely a much credit to him too with
his support of this project as well as
this presentation so moving forward we
have some quick learning objectives the
first is to describe the state of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning in society versus laboratory
medicine I take it that most of the
audience members today are from the
laboratory field so we're going to try
to relate to what we've been exposed to
in AI and ml in society and how this
could impact us today in our professions
we also want to identify practices
specifically best practices for
developing and validating health-related
AI and ML algorithms and lastly describe
the clinical value of artificial
intelligence and machine learning for
sepsis acute kidney injury as it relates
to a high-risk population that we're
going to focus on which are burn
patients so let's ask that question what
is artificial intelligence and machine
learning I think over the last couple
years and
most recently last year or two we've
heard about AI and machine learning all
over the media and so forth we wanted to
catch everyone up to the same wavelength
here and really define what AI and
machine learning is and what you
consider AI to be is really the
overreaching field in this case AI is a
branch of computer science dealing with
simulation of intelligent behavior and
computers it's pretty much giving
machines the ability to imitate
intelligent human behavior but where
does machine learning fall under well
it's a subcategory of AI for all intents
and purposes and it's a process by which
a computer is able to improve on its own
so you give it new data it's gonna get
better
and then as it continues to move on
throughout its use it will continue to
evolve quote-unquote and become better
and better hopefully and use it because
of statistics to achieve these goals and
then last but certainly not least a very
exciting area of artificial intelligence
and machine learning is deep learning
and this is the use of very
sophisticated AI algorithms which
effectively generate artificial neural
networks mimicking what we have in our
brain to continue to learn and become
better and this concept of an involving
machine both creates excitement and also
fear by law society from the fear
standpoint the question comes up all the
time
will a I take over and you can see here
with references to various forms of
media movies and so forth there is that
one day a I could figure out that humans
are the threat as an example and
jokingly they decide to take care of us
for better for worse and this has
created undue unneeded fear in this very
revolutionary technology that could
potentially help us but at the end of
the day it relies on how we use it to
ultimately dictate how what type of
effect it has on our society we don't
have to go far though to see how a AI
and ml is already changing our lives
already as you are
probably browsing the web throughout the
day we have search engines that rely
heavily on artificial intelligence using
Google for example here which is a very
popular search engine you'll see that as
you typing in your search parameters
it's already trying to predict what you
the individual may want and oddly enough
what you search you also see other
things that are reference to what you
may be interested in so these are all
very sophisticated mechanisms and
machine learning and artificial
intelligence that are being used every
day every second we also see social
media leveraging artificial intelligence
so from the standpoint of facial
recognition where you post a picture of
yourself on on search and social media
it asks you is this you so it's
recognizing features of your face and
linking it with you as the individual we
of course see certain stores in this
case online store is a very large one in
this case identify your preferences for
things you want to buy again machine
learning control here your phone the
powerful technology in your hands using
recently even as a last night as I
talked about I have a update for one of
my phones saying now it's adding a new
software to be able to leverage the deep
learning capabilities of this new phone
that we purchased and you can see here
again it's using this to be able to
identify faces any other features to be
able to the day our daily lives and of
course we've seen a couple years ago
that machine learning a I have also
bested humanity in game shows in this
case jeopardy so this is the famous case
where IBM Watson beat contestants on the
game show and of course the emerging
evolution of self-driving vehicles it
goes like that now driving with cameras
all around them taking many pictures at
every frame per second to then determine
is it in the middle of the road does it
need to avoid a person doesn't he avoid
another car and so forth all this is
happening right now as we speak and then
some so where do we start with AI and
Hulk here because we see it now in our
everyday so
society but what about health care is AI
already here what do we do how do we
actually get AI going in this very
important field this is a paper that we
recently published a review paper
doctoral she's the first off it here in
academic pathology but effectively
you'll see here that it's a four-step
process at minimum we've we've
deconstructed down to the four steps to
keep it simple for everyone but it
really involves first part is knowing
what data you have how good it is you
then apply it to an artificial
intelligence model or machine learning
model you validate it internally you
identify optimal parameters and then
number step three you assess for its
generalizability and lastly you verify
the performance in the real world and
we'll go through each of these right now
so how good is your data that's the most
important question you should ask as we
know in healthcare in the electronic
medical record varies in the quality of
data most EMRs today are designed to
design to optimize billing
rather than really to help with patient
care people will may disagree with me
but if anyone who has done clinical
research and had tried to abstract data
first it's not a great experience but at
the end of the day you want to look at
how valid the data is is it complete is
there sufficient data points so the
density is it potentially generalizable
to other populations in other places and
how does it compare against real-world
versus research datasets because you
could be using a clinical trial data set
versus EMR data so ultimately to take
home here is getting junk out if you
have bad data you're gonna make a bad AI
that's pretty much what it ends up being
but you also have to figure out how to
convert data that is dirty what we like
to call Derna so dirty data to automate
to clean data and ultimately you have to
ask yourself that question how do we
convert that in that clean data to make
it into actual knowledge so you have to
find wise relevant and clean it forth to
move forward with these AI efforts and
then we have the valley and optimize and
validation optimization is always a
balance between fitting overfitting and
underfitting it to an AI model
if you're over or under fitting a model
as you can see here with the bottom row
below model complexity you don't match
the data but you try to match it too
much or or don't match it sufficiently
the error rates get significantly high
so finding that sweet spot where you
find that nice balance between variants
versus bias and the error rate really
helps decide the best model to move
forward with and that really comes down
to somewhat of empiricism but there may
be new technologies in the future that
help do this more automatically but the
end of day it's like Goldilocks finding
the model that is just right and then
the last is certain at least assessing
the general generalizability of the
model and verifying if it works in the
real world and of course
generalizability is hugely important
showing the slide here from the same
review paper that we have we bring in
more data can our data set in for
example in Pediatrics be translated to
adults or vice versa can our data at
uc-davis be translated to our colleagues
in San Diego those are generalizability
studies that we have to do and also most
importantly once we determine that it
can be generalizable on research data
can it work in the real world where
there's a lot of incompleteness in data
sets such as from the electronic medical
records and so forth and it emphasizes
this important these cross validation
studies where training data sets
additional secondary data sets are
brought in to further validate and
ultimately deploy in the real world so
the question comes up is despite our
great intense for patient safety trying
to improve the quality of patient care
and our innovativeness and using
artificial intelligence how far have we
gotten in terms of AI unfortunately the
real world is a tough place and here's a
great article from MD Anderson and
several years ago MD Anderson taps IBM
Watson remember IBM Watson was that
artificial intelligence that beat human
players in jeopardy and their intent was
to pretty much put this in
what's called the oncology expert
advisor to help physicians target
appropriate cancer therapy and they
stated a new era of computing has
emerged in which cognitive systems
understands the context within users
questions uncovers answers from big data
and improve in performance by
continuously learning from experiences
and that's what machine learning and AI
is all about but the reality is is as
the title implies the real world is a
tough place it didn't work it was a
major setback for AI and in this case in
medicine and what was highlight it was
first about 62 million dollars was
wasted without achieving goals the group
conceded that treating cancer is more
complex than winning a trivia game and
the vast universe of medical knowledge
may not be as significant as purveyors
of AI make it out to be so where do we
go from here how do we avoid the
pitfalls that that were encountered by
MD Anderson as well as others and how do
we ultimately navigate this my potential
minefield of creating a safe but
effective AI ml in healthcare especially
in the laboratory the answer is simple
why don't we just look at a low-hanging
fruit let's start small so we can learn
let's start learn how to crawl before we
can walk and before we can run so with
that said we decided to go down the
pathway of evaluating AI in a high-risk
population and this is burn patients and
burn patients in particular or an
extreme risk for sepsis burn sepsis
occurs frequently in burn patients
because of the fact they've lost their
primary barrier to the environment so
your skin is a big role matching
infections as you can imagine the
majority of brain related deaths are due
to sepsis multi organ dysfunction is
actually the most common about 97% of
burn patients experience sepsis in their
state or some sort of infection
so early recognition is difficult
because it's despite the that we said
every year a new definition for sepsis
and I am exaggerating every couple of
years the problem is these definitions
for sepsis that we know and love and non
burn patients don't really apply this is
because of the fact that burn patients
have severe tissue injury their
hypermetabolic and there's massive
inflammation to highlight this as you
can see these are old and new
definitions of ignorance as non burn
patients and you can see here that
recall what's called stirs s IRS or the
systemic inflammatory response syndrome
where they tell you of your hypothermic
or hyperthermic with a temperature
greater than 38 degrees Celsius for
fever you have a heart rate of greater
than 90 beats per minute a respiratory
rate greater than 20 breaths permit
really high or really low white cell
counts also suggest that you have an
inflammatory response going on and then
if you meet ATS criteria on the Left
where you have a presumed or identified
source infection with these search
criteria and others you have sepsis and
that's pretty straightforward but the
reality is though as we move forward and
looking on this next line right here the
baseline profile of an acutely burn
patient they have a temperature of 38 to
39 degrees Celsius they are always
febrile quote-unquote they always have
90 to 110 beats per minute for their
heart rate they're always breathing
faster and their white cell counts are
can be really higher really low
this is due to the inflammatory response
so when you have these confounding
factors and the fact that burned pages
all exhibit sirs we have a problem in
teasing out the one sepsis patient 20
that are just inflamed and this is a
potential AI ml opportunity so we
decided to look at a unique data set
that we had Davis we had the opportunity
I was the principal investigator for
this was to do a multicenter randomized
trial in this case it looked at sepsis
and used technology to detect infectious
more quickly we had 218 patients from
more burn centers Davis was included as
you can see here on the left and this
serve is a nice dataset in addition to
accomplish
what we did for the grant for the new
device we were testing we now have a
large very clean data set with all these
test parameters these vital signs and
other things paired to these patients
across 218 adult patients with 20% or
more it's just a highlight a percent
area burn for you or I it's roughly
about one side of your hand so a 20%
burn it's comparable to a little bit
more than both your arms being burned
obviously people maybe burn in different
places in their body so our first
attempt here and we'll go into more
detail about these techniques is that we
looked at if an AML technique could be
better than a regular visiting burn
sepsis and it shows with this receiver
operator characteristic curves it
actually has areas underneath these
curves of about 0.68 2.86 obviously the
one with 0.86 the bigger one is better
this is a paper we just I've submitted
and these are the variables we looked at
for these burn patients on the
sensitivity was 96% with specificity a
76% so it serves as a great screening
tool and compared to traditional
statistical methods that were used to
help define current burn metrics of
sepsis the specificity was actually 84
to 62% for these old techniques so we
were more sensitive and more specific
which is fantastic but during this
process we also realized that a lot of
burn patients with sepsis or even
without acquired a significant amount of
acute kidney injury in fact 45% of these
burn patients in our 218 patient dataset
had acute kidney injury and yes sepsis
was fun we showed good data and we're
continuing to move on it but it isn't
really low hanging fruit sepsis is quite
dangerous in terms of misidentifying so
it this revelation allowed us to refocus
and go let's first look at a ki first
because a ki is common secondary to
sepsis as well as burn injury so let's
now look at a model for using AI for a
ki
this paper published in 2015 we did
something um this is paper published by
dr. somin Sandy's my colleague and I was
the last author in his paper because it
was a siphoner under one of our grants
and just to get folks on the same page
acute kidney injury can is obviously
direct damage to the kidneys in whether
it be due to lack of blood flow some pre
renal causes direct damage to the
nephrons and the actual prank coma of
the kidney so intrinsic pathways there's
blockage prevents you know urinary
elimination so common causes of 8ki of
course are sepsis nephrotoxic
medications which occur from the
antibiotics would give duda sepsis as
well as something called burns shock
which will elaborate very shortly
a study by Tina Palmieri who is our burn
director and Damons show that up to 58
percent of our patients experience 8ki
so what's a homeland disease so going
down a pipeline we decide to look at 30
patients these are all adults again with
equal or more than 20% total body
surface area burns and the important
thing to realize is that some of these
patients will be getting a ki or not the
reason why patients are at risk for a ki
especially in the early days admission
is they get what's called burn shock
because of the systemic inflammation
there's massive vasodilation which
reduces their blood pressure but also
this is confounded by the lack of skin
where the skin also keeps our water in
so through convective and evaporative
water loss the patients lose a lot of
volume and therefore become extremely
hypotensive
hence merged shock so there isn't a need
to be able to look at burn patients in
the first 48 hours to determine if
they're at risk for a ki so you see the
two populations here we don't know which
the current paradigm for for a ki is
what's called a que digo criteria which
is not represented here this is the
original rifle criteria which is an
acronym for risk injury failure loss and
end-stage renal disease as you move down
that rifle acronym these are in the risk
and and severity is based on how much
you urinate per hour or your GFR your
glomerular filtration rate obviously as
those
deviate from normal you don't look so
well so in this study we found that 14
pages were categorized as having a ki
and in the remaining 16 out of 30 did
not so this is based on chart review and
based on the rifle criteria quickly the
demographics for these two populations
were similar age burn size gender ratios
were similar but I do want to note that
a ki patients despite having kidney
injury in the first 48 within that first
week but in the first 48 hours of data
their creatinine their mean arterial
pressure their central venous pressure
and urine output we're statistically
similar to the non Aki population so
somewhere somehow after two days these
patients convert over and the kidney
injury fully manifests itself in that
first week however you do identify if
you use a biomarker called n gal and
we'll talk about what that is shortly
and the a biomarker is statistically
significantly higher in Aki patients
within that first 48 hours than non Aki
patients and gal is an abbreviation for
what's called neutrophil gelatinous
gelatinous associated lipo Kaylin and
you can see here that it is produced by
neutrophils hence the name it's filtered
by the kidney but during injury because
the filtration decrease neutrophil the
neutrophil gelatinous associated lipo
Kaylin levels rise in plasma and
uniquely real tubular cells start
producing head gal as well so you'll
have more in the urine coming back in
the urine or coming out in the urine and
coming back into the bloodstream to in
addition to all that is being produced
by neutrophils so and Gao becomes a very
sensitive and specific biomarker for Aki
so we decided to use that dataset and
it's been augmented and this is was
recently accepted published in 2019
paper and burns so it just it just came
out and we decided to use that data that
is augmented by an additional 23
patients we had n gal but also augmented
across all 53 samples with n terminal
Pro B and P testing which assesses the
cardiac stress that is due to cardial
reno syndrome from aki obviously we do n
gal we also do creatinine remember the
30 patients are from the last population
and we could differentiate official
intelligence what we found this using AI
we were able to identify a ki a lot
earlier in fact about forty two point
seven hours earlier you can see the two
groups here you actually split out
fifty-fifty quite well excuse me but
again demographics were similar between
the two population during output were
not helpful and you also know that that
again plasma India was significantly
higher in this population looking at ROC
curves excuse me
ROC curves BNP and n gal were the
superstars here with areas on the curve
for this ROC curve 0.8 three and point
nine effectively and got performed well
on its own as well so we hypothesize
here that both end gallon BMP may work
well together so what approaches do we
use well the main approach is that we
originally looked at and we've moved on
this in recent times is looking at K
nearest neighbor random forests and
support vector machine K nearest
neighbor is effectively a technique
where we cluster the data based on their
outcome a ki or not we define an area to
divide them and see how far they are
from that point you see there so we want
to classify red dots versus black dots
in that case random force effectively
generates a random series of decision
trees and then through voting composite
voting or ensemble voting in this case
whichever is the majority wins and
therefore it votes who has API or not
based on again randomly generated
algorithms support vector machine little
bit fancier technology or technique in
this case you can see that sometimes
data doesn't spread nicely doesn't
divide evenly between some x and y plane
and you can see here that you know red
dots and black dots are separate
reasonably well the top left of the
support vector machine bigger but
there's still a black dot sitting in
that area
so the support vector machine can then
generate a contour line you can see in
that bottom figure right there
it separates things out a little bit
nicely but again it's still having
issues with fully separating it out so
you can use fancy techniques a kernel
trick in this case it's just fancy math
so then convert this to a 3d plane so
you can actually separate things out
more in a 3d space rather than
two-dimensional graph for this first
paper we only use K nearest neighbors
just to try it out and through this
process and K tells you how many
neighbor you cluster the data ultimately
you can see here that the data when we
trained it and then tested it to
validate it it actually performed well
after a certain number of neighbors
x-axis is K values a number of neighbors
you can see that other y-axis is the
percent accuracy and the take-home was
that if we actually had a model that use
ng IB and peak reading you're now now
creating a bit alone the models work
reasonably well with accuracies in the
range of 90% and above however when you
exclude and gal the models get
progressively worse in fact if you
remove BNP and and y'all together you
ultimately have a crag in urine output
and you can see how terrible the
performance is in penalty so ultimately
this allows us to be able to to know
that these models can augment the
performance of existing biomarkers such
as with ng out credi and your an output
or BNP Kranti and your an output but
creating your an output alone are not
good enough even though they're used as
criteria for a ki today so focusing on
that model right there again we lack end
gap but looking closer we're achieving
and in terms of the orange line that's
what we use to validate blue line was
what we use to train the data set we are
able to achieve roughly 8 90% accuracy
across the board for most of these
parameters without end Gallo so we don't
necessarily need end gal and gal helps
it does augments it but if you're a
place that doesn't have any gal you can
use AI to augment its existing
performance which is a very interesting
tool
this then brings up the hypothesis then
could we actually deploy a a I early
using these combinations of biomarkers
to differentiate patients earlier hence
being able to predict a key I with
artificial intelligence about two days
earlier than traditional techniques so
this moves us next to the next paper we
had it and in this case this is where we
focus on the generalization of the burn
data we decided to move beyond K nearest
neighbors we still used it but it
include the two other techniques as
outlined here random forest and support
vector machine we did a much larger data
set so this initial burn cohort of fifty
patients we analyzed it with the two
other techniques random for us an SVM
the accuracy is an average accuracy on
the left as well as the x-axis showed
the different combination of biomarkers
and you can see that again we do see
that phenomena using the three
techniques now rather than just K
nearest neighbors that we can't augment
the performance without end gal when
using AI but we now have a new court we
brought in an additional in this case
you see that there are combined burn
trauma cohort we decided to do this is
because we want a stress test we have a
cohort or a I I was trained only on burn
patients let's see how it works when it
has a mixed population of burned and non
burned patients but again we do see that
there is better performance and the
reality here is that it actually Aki
even earlier so the last paper showed it
was close to two days about forty two
hours earlier now we're able to predict
it sixty one point eight hours earlier
including in patients that were even
burned so the conclusions I have for
this is pretty straight forward
artificial intelligence for burn related
sepsis is a cat is feasible it works
it's just the data that you have you
have to make sure it's clean going in
burn sepsis AI peers to perform better
than traditional indicators and then Aki
enriched and machine learning augments
the performance of these legacy
biomarkers such as BNP creatinine and
urine output we actually also showed
that if we have an aki artificial
intelligence algorithms trained on burn
data alone it can work and non burn
trauma patients
however we do caution that artificial
intelligence is still in its infancy yes
there are cars out there that are semi
autonomously driving on their own yes we
have search engines and cameras and and
gameshow winners that are based on AI
but in healthcare there's still a lot we
have to resolve
there are obviously are the
technological challenges but also the
sociological challenges in regulatory
barriers questions that have recently
come up in paper in JAMA have asked
who's liable when you're using AI is it
the person taking the decision or is the
person who made the AI lots of questions
there the quality of data and the
appropriateness of how you validate
these artificial intelligence and
returning machine learning algorithms
and how you utilize appropriate
analytics are all critical in making
sure that these new novel ways to
analyze data to make decisions work
safely and efficiently in the healthcare
or in a complex healthcare environment
so just acknowledge the burden data and
pods data that you see here are from
various grants that mentor the mentor
clinical research training program at
Davis was actually NIH funded and the
second dataset was sponsored by the
internal quality project at UC Davis
deploying and gal and AI for laboratory
purposes we are in fact actually
expanding this and working to deploy it
clinically after going through the
appropriate process so with that said
I'm happy to take questions from folks I
know this is a recorded record
presentation so I believe I will see
these questions in the email and I'll be
delighted to respond back to your
questions and comments and thank you
again for taking the time to hear this
talk